you know when you talk about the protest
that happened in 2017
uh by some far left people at that time
like
as bad as it was i thought at that time
i actually
quite miss it because at that time it
was people
just yelling and making a scene and
trying to interrupt events
unfortunately since then political
violence has continued to devolve
not just in portland but actually
through many
american cities and throughout 2020
portland and seattle became the
epicenter
of far left american violence
where in my home city the city
you've been to several times to speak
there were more than
120 days of recurring nightly
violence so you're in los
angeles i know there was some writing
that happened after george floyd died
imagine what you saw there happening for
four months straight
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an american journalist best known for
covering the antifa
protests in portland and author of the
new
already best-selling book unmasked
inside antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy
andy no my friend welcome back to the
reuben report
thank you dave it's so nice to be
speaking with you again
last time uh we met in studio was
shortly after i was beaten
yeah uh you were you were hurting i mean
you were actually still
in in quite a bit of pain and and you
were medicated and everything else i
actually think that's probably the
the best place we can start because i
was trying to chronicle just the amount
of time
that i've known you and i think i sort
of came aware of you we've
we've sort of risen in the online world
or whatever it is
starting in around 2015 or so in 2016
or 2017 i did an event at portland state
university and
and obviously you're from portland
that's where you do most of your work
and i've uncovered most of this antifa
stuff there
i did an event with christina hoff
sommers the feminist and peter bogosian
the
uh philosophy professor and antifa was
there it was the first time that they
had ever protested anything that i had
been part of
they called me a homophobe of course
they called uh christina misogynist of
course they call peter a white
supremacist of course
and we did an event that you know had to
have a lot of security and there was a
lot of tension and police had to escort
us in the whole thing
anyway i mention all of that because i
met you right after the event because
you were covering it and you were
you know you were sort of just uh with
all due respect my friend you you were
like a kid journalist and you were just
kind of figuring out your thing and now
you've become
the center of what's going on with
antifa so first off my
my hat off to you uh and and now that
i've talked enough to start the show
can you talk just a little bit about
that just sort of where you
started with this whole thing because
now everyone just thinks you're part of
it
but you were you were just a scrappy kid
trying to
do journalism yeah that's right dave
actually i was part of the student group
that organized the event that invited
you so
just uh four years ago i was just this
student journalist part of the free
expression group uh
at university who was a fan of yours and
you know it's been such a um privilege
to
to not just become better friends with
you over the years but then like
to to rise up in our in our um careers
and in work
because it's really linked and i think
you know when you talk about the
protests that happened in 2017
uh by some far left people at that time
like
as bad as it was i thought at that time
i actually
quite miss it because at that time it
was people just yelling and making a
scene
and trying to interrupt events
unfortunately
since then political violence has
continued to devolve
not just in portland but actually
through many
american cities and throughout 2020
portland and seattle became the at the
center of far left
american violence
where in my home city the city
you've been to several times to speak
there were more than
120 days of recurring nightly violence
so you're in los angeles i know there
was
some writing that happened after george
floyd died imagine
what you saw there happening for four
months straight that's what happened in
portland and it's still ongoing now
it's just become weekly but it's picked
up speed
um this week alone we had let's see
three riots in portland involving antifa
so so when you started seeing this right
so you as you said you were part of a
student group you invite a couple people
that
we all considered ourselves good liberal
moderates
and i remember before the event because
there was this threat of violence they
had to hide us in a room and we had a
police escort that had to take us from
one room
to the event by the way the event ended
up being spectacular it's
it's online we'll link to it in the in
the bio here and it was fun
and you know fortunately there was no
violence but people were angry outside
um do you so you that was sort of the
beginning of all of this
then over the last couple years it just
kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger
why what was it about it that you saw
that you knew that this was going to
happen because you've been tracking it
the whole time
well i knew it wasn't just a university
or campus phenomenon what we were
experiencing since going back to around
2015 that the
ideology that was justifying these
outbursts
far-left rage and sometimes violence on
campuses
would in that inevitably spill out to
the wider cities where these
universities are and where these
students were returning to
and so and that's exactly what happened
very quickly in portland and i think the
turning point particularly for its
moving spilling out
pouring out from macadine into the
streets
was the surprise election winner donald
trump so that just
gave an excuse for all the excesses of
the far left
to go out and wreak havoc in the name of
anti-fascism and anti-racism and social
justice and they were given
the legitimacy they needed through the
mainstream media and through
unfortunately left-wing democrat
politicians
yeah okay so for people that just see
the videos now and we've all seen the
videos of what's going on in portland
and seattle and everywhere else for
people that are sort of just watching
from the outside that haven't been to
events
you know i've been protested many times
you actually helped another video that i
was part of go viral when i was
up in canada and antifa showed up and
they were
uh protesting that woman in the in the
walker
trying to cross the street calling her a
nazi it turned out of course that her
husband was a veteran of world war ii
who
literally fought nazis uh but these are
the types of things that you've seen
over and over
for people that don't really pay
attention though that just see those
little viral videos and unfortunately
you don't see them on mainstream enough
what is antifa
see the videos i don't think truly
show the threat we're facing them some
of them do but i mean
like these extremists carried out
in interaction in my city
where night after night they were going
with knives
and guns and explosives and organizing
themselves
into different units in a marauding gang
essentially starting fires and
they eventually killed somebody but
to answer your question what is antifa
it is
a movement in ideology and shadowy
networks
of people who call themselves
anti-fascists but actually espouse
inanicus communist extremist ideology
so the re there's a lot of meaning
in their acts of violence i know it can
look kind of
meaningless without purpose
but for example the attacks on the
federal courthouse in portland last july
that lasted for weeks when they tried to
burn down that federal
facility that was because they viewed
the american criminal justice system as
a system of enslavement of racism uh
a remaining relic of white supremacy
that's why they were doing that that's
why they attacked law enforcement and
called for its abolishment that's why
they go after
property rights as well they view
capitalism as intrinsically linked to
racism and so like bit by bit they've
gone after
not just like literal institutions in
america but actually i think more
fundamentally the founding
ideals the rule of law freedom of
expression
i mean antifa are probably most known
for
their anti-freedom of expression and
that
they believe it is the not just
appropriate but righteous response
to be preemptively violent to people who
have
wrong think or spouse the wrong views if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell